[Musique]
l'armée de terre recrute aussi à
Besançon sur les 450 jeunes venus se
renseigner en 2021 seulement 151 ont
signé un contrat avec la concurrence
accrue sur le marché du travail les
militaires admettent avoir un peu plus
de difficultés à enrouler mais ils ont
des arguments
je pense qu'ils viennent pour le côté
vraiment atypique le fait qu'on fait un
métier vraiment qui est hors du commun
et qui vivront des choses dans l'armée
de terre qui ne vivront nulle part
ailleurs en fait c'est ça qui les attire
plus que la sécurité de l'emploi c'est
sûr
une fois intégré les recrues s'engagent
à fond dans leur métier une vocation au
sens classique du terme ils en rêvaient
déjà tout petit on vient pas nous
prendre par la main pour venir à l'armée
c'est nous qui décidons d'aller à
l'armée du coup on est pour moi on est
tous dans la même optique
de la vocation
très jeune ont plus de mal à s'orienter
vers un métier dans cet atelier de
formation du lycée Jules Haag de
Besançon la précision et la complexité
du décolletage a séduit des lycéens
une forme de dépassement qui leur a
permis de trouver leur voie moi j'avais
du mal déjà trouvé ce que j'aimais j'ai
pris beaucoup de temps à savoir ce que
je voulais faire ça veut dire que ça m'a
avant d'être sûr de faire ça ça m'a pris
beaucoup de beaucoup de temps donc ici
je desserre
en tenant mon doigt c'est pas un métier
comme les autres c'est plus difficile et
c'est un métier qui est complet
et il faut aimer pour pour réussir à
faire léo je t'en prie dans les lycées
les psychologues de l'éducation
nationale sont là pour aider les élèves
pour Barbara Ritz la vocation comme on
pouvait l'entendre avant n'existe plus
vraiment
nous sommes dans une société qui fait
beaucoup appel à l'incertitude et nous
sommes dans une telle transition
majeure actuellement sur sur beaucoup
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'innovations
parce que il y a le monde a complètement
changé et ce n'est plus le monde aussi
fixe qu'on avait au sortir des années
des années 60-80 où il était si
prétictible on dit par exemple qu'il y a
la moitié des métiers qui ne sont pas
connus à l'heure actuelle
sur les réseaux sociaux
cette conseillère en carrière donne les
clés pour apprivoiser ce monde du
travail en constante évolution moi ce
qui me convient pas dans le terme
vocation c'est l'idée que qu'il y ait
une adéquation quelque part une case
pour quelqu'un pour tout le monde ce
serait un voilà c'est comme un peu
autour de l'âme sœur là il y a un peu ça
peut être vrai pour certains mais c'est
pas vrai pour tout le monde et c'est pas
pour ça qu'on peut pas être heureux au
travail donc je pense qu'il faut parler
plutôt de plusieurs vocations plusieurs
intérêts professionnels dans une vie
professionnelle plutôt que une vocation
comme si c'était quelque chose de posé
et qui participe à notre identité
professionnelle unique
qui dit plusieurs vocations dans une vie
dit changement de trajectoire en
coiffure la vocation ne dure plus
forcément toute une vie
recruter des jeunes pour démarrer dans
la profession c'est assez facile
recruter pour une pour quelqu'un de
qualifié c'est un peu plus compliqué il
y a une perte une perte des gens en fait
dans la profession au bout de quelques
années de métiers ou
il y a un changement d'orientation une
un des intérêts qui se passe
qu'on constate en fait au bout de
quelques années une passion qui peut
prendre du temps à se révéler Kevin
vient de reprendre des études à l'école
afco à 27 ans le monde du travail il
connaît j'ai déjà fait les deux j'ai
déjà fait un taf ou un bar on s'en va
pour prendre des sous et puis après là
j'ai maintenant que je suis en coiffure
je fais quelque chose que j'aime donc ça
veut dire que je vais au travail j'aime
ce que je fais le rapport il est plus du
tout le même
on m'a toujours appris fait quelque
chose bien et l'argent viendra après et
moi je faisais l'inverse avant
définition sur le thème de la permanente
aujourd'hui les jeunes ils ont envie
d'avoir un mythique qui leur plaise mais
ils ont envie aussi de préserver je
pense leur vie personnelle donc le
challenge on va dire de des années qui
viennent c'est de trouver justement
comment faire pour garder ces jeunes
motivés respecter aussi leur nous leur
nouvelle leur nouvelle préoccupation
mais répondre quand même aux besoins du
monde du travail qui est important non
chef d'entreprise on essaie enfin en ce
qui me concerne j'essaie d'adapter au
mieux les plannings pour que les
salariés qui ont des enfants par exemple
puissent avoir leur mercredi et puis
travailler chez des salariés qui
travaillent quatre jours par semaine par
exemple
travailler avec des jeunes enfants voilà
ce que veulent faire ces étudiants qui
préparent à lire TS de Besançon un
diplôme bac + 3 et le cours du jour
tombe à pic est-ce que
on demande qu'aux salariés Kojo
professionnel de la petite enfance de
s'adapter à n'importe quel prix ou
est-ce que on porte une attention
à la question
des conditions de travail je sais qu'en
sortant de la formation si ça se passe
correctement je suis censé gagner un peu
plus que quelqu'un qui a fait juste une
année de service quoi puis enfin le but
c'est aussi de pouvoir avoir une vie à
côté quoi hormis le salaire il y a la
reconnaissance parce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut-être peut expliquer
certains dysfonctionnements à l'heure
actuelle
la valorisation ça passe comme je disais
par le salaire mais pas que il y a aussi
toutes les petites choses à côté
ça peut être de
reconnaître de travailler effectué au
quotidien justement
en ayant des mots bienveillants
[Musique]
en félicitant les professionnels quand
ils accomplissent leur mission au
quotidien et pas uniquement de souligner
ce qui va mal
il y a un besoin de confort le confort
pour eux c'est peut-être pas le même
confort que des générations avaient il y
a 10 ans ou 20 ans ça peut être des
horaires ça peut être des conditions de
travail ça peut être des salaires ça
peut être combien j'aurai de congés pour
si je prends cet emploi là il y a ça
aussi la demande de chacun par rapport à
un concept de vie
dans le Doubs l'association des Francas
emploie 55 salariés pour ces lieux
d'accueil de la petite enfance elle
emploie des éducateurs jeunes enfants
des infirmières des CAP petite enfance
et des auxiliaires de puériculture des
métiers recherchés ces dernières années
les crèches se sont beaucoup développées
je crois pas ce qui est une crise
d'évocation
je ne crois pas parce que au regard de
ce qu'on peut effectivement rencontrer
en entretien je pense que les gens sont
aujourd'hui sont aujourd'hui armés
sont aujourd'hui motivés pour engager
leur cette vocation professionnelle ils
sont en revanche je pense et c'est
légitime de leur part en recherche de
structures avec un une qualité de vie au
travail et ça c'est encore des éléments
sur lesquels nous on doit progresser
parce que vous ne pouvez pas un moment
donné exiger toute la bienveillance dont
les petits ont besoin sans qu'à un
moment donné au niveau des adultes du
coup il est des déficits
organisationnels ou de gestion ou de
politiques RH au niveau des employeurs
et si cette difficulté de recruter ne
venait pas d'une crise d'évocation mais
plutôt de l'émergence d'un autre rapport
au travail moi je crois qu'il y a plus
une crise de la carrière que d'évocation
les gens ne conçoivent pas leur carrière
de la même façon que il y a 10 ans avant
l'idée c'était le modèle de la girafe de
monter toujours plus haut ça c'était une
carrière réussie et puis aujourd'hui
c'est plus le mode abeille j'ai le droit
d'aller voir l'un d'aller goûter autre
chose du moment que je ramène ce qu'il
faut pour faire du miel à la ruche c'est
un peu l'idée et du moment que que je
voilà que je respecte aussi je fais bien
mon travail
tous les jeunes que nous avons rencontré
lors de ce tournage sont passionnés par
leur métier ou leur futur profession il
exerceront quelques années ou toute leur
vie ils changeront de voix auront de
nouvelles vocations ils auront d'autres
envies pour continuer d'aimer leur
travail
[Musique]